ich hatte dann ultra geile idee für ein
video heute bin ich gerade hier in
wieder fällt bei meiner familie und um
diese idee umsetzen können wir nach köln
fahren die scheiße es halt auch ihre
ideen nicht er irgendwie ein paar tagen
umgesetzt werden kann sondern das muss
heute passieren
natürlich war ich jetzt extra dafür
wieder nach köln
leute ich bin jetzt hier in köln
angekommen könnte es tatsächlich übels
gutes wetter nicht alleine jetzt sondern
tatsächlich mit sebastian weil wir
werden jetzt auf jeden fall etwas
zusammen regieren was für den verein auf
jeden fall brauchen ist ein luftballon
mit aufschrift die beide werden im jahr
zum geburtstag eine torte schenken ihr
rund ist und zwar tot aber einfach nur
ein luftballon mit mit viel schlagsahne
rubio stückchen drauf und wir damit ein
riesiges leider gehen wir in matter soll
auch schnell an putz und max bude
explodiert dabei warum schwanz
[Musik]
als allererstes die cofra findet dann
den wir jetzt hier auch bei den new york
angekommen das heißt eine packung
normale vorgehen für auch schon gestern
haben wir hier auch noch meine damen und
herren wir haben hier noch das
wichtigste was wir benötigen herbst eine
dann brauchen wir vor dem spiel war das
heißt wird sagen monaten himmelskörper 2
wir haben alles selbst gemacht wieder
fähig das andere ich bin für den
vorreiter wird mein leben der anderen
worten das wäre für mich auch genug
geleistet
vorbesteller von fertig ja wichtig nicht
in frage kommt er ruft mich an luca
schaffen bin ich wie sage abfuhr da bist
du achten können daraus geschnitten
stock fünf packungen schlägt also leute
wie jene in etwa wie folgt wir haben
hier doch welche gibt es zwei de facto
raytion doppelseitige klebeband nach
wird hier gut wissen auch dass letztere
natürlich auch ein bisschen meine damen
und herren fangen wir an mit der ersten
garde
und weil der schwede wir müssen jetzt
noch immer zum alltag oder irgendwie
sogar das bett einfach glaube ich
wirklich wenn hier so pape noch drum
machen weil familia zion ja ich habe
keine waffe eine ewigkeit
[Musik]
also leute was ich jetzt mache das hier
lernte durchschneiden erklärte lag das
hat sich dann ein bisschen rum rumstehen
oder steht es wirklich einmal lukas
prinz william shatner von winterfeld und
leben damit
wenn ihr borgward dass ich meinen weg
kanal auch machen wo ich torten backen
dann lass leiter und bei rohstoffen 100
millionen filmstreifen des hier dran
kommen sonst könnte ich aber damit nicht
festigen sowie das ganze einigermaßen
autofahrer nehmen eine neue und packend
war bisschen spaß war die beste
ich bin begeistert bewerb zum bisschen
angst wenn das jetzt ab rutscht das ist
über eine kante drüber geht tag erwischt
alles ab ich hätte vielleicht ein
bisschen tackmann lassen sollen tot
das gebiet nicht fest alter schalte ich
finde es schon kommen die laufenbrücke
oder fängt es an zu regnen
einige leute nicht aber für mich das
hier wird keine veränderung somit
eigentlich eine aktive am rand fällt
heute die letzte tagung schlagartig dass
wir vorne an die weiteren pläne hier war
relativ hart das streichen darunter das
problem ist auch noch mal in den
kilometer zu laufen
man biete überall so leichter oder
mittwoch wieder im wieder man das
praktisch aber ich hoffe einfach noch
beim castroper straße darüber mit 22
die broschüre leuten da alle
mettenleiter wie finde ich schon eine
sieben stunden mit sieben stunden stunde
der raw datei angekommen
sie hätten die forscher erst mit dem
doppelseitigen klebeband machen können
wenn sie schon mal weit gewesen welche
einfach fotografieren
leute also ich vergessen waren überall
mit rahmen meiner möglichkeiten mehr
werben 5 lag dollar gekauft ich dachte
das langweilt aber überhaupt nicht
entwickler also man wie zumindest keine
rosa schwellen mehr gerade das muss man
jetzt mal sagen werden auf jeden fall
anders angehen wird oder in den laptop
die scheitere der plan ion und glücklich
wird das heiße vielleicht auf jeden fall
mal zu machen aber erst vom herzog
gestreute hier oben noch das ganze mit
worte aus sie dann noch obendrauf packen
aber das lassen wer braucht da noch die
kehrpflicht auf jeden fall auch noch
eine irgendwie forderte auch in der
kunst alles machen nur 5000 noch die
reste werden so auch meine damen und
herren festgeschrieben dass der sommer
kommen das heißt wir sehen uns im
nächsten kann ein wachsen der tat noch
in kurzen messer ein und anfahren immer
gutes wetter so leute der mittsommer
neue spiele gekauft und in der
steiermark zu hause und werden das jetzt
immer hier drauf und das blöd halten
viele meiner wohnung die vita der warm
war deswegen ob ich das papier zumindest
ein bisschen drauf liegen bleiben
kommt ihr uns
[Applaus]
okay leute ich bin jetzt wieder zurück
in meiner wohnung angekommen
der trainer hat auf jeden fall
erfolgreich geklappt hat soll darauf
eingefallen dass gerade wie direktor
ende geschnitten haben etwas gefallen
hat wie gern man like da wir den bock
auf mehr solcher spontanen dumme aktion
von mir habt kommt findet ihr hier eine
smiley eingeblendet wenn ihr da draußen
könnte meinen kanal kosten und
abonnieren darunter findet ihr ein video
eingeblendet wo ich irgendwas anderes
gemacht hat also hab' meinen kanal
kompletter video an und machen schönen
tag